les images sont dignes d'un film
catastrophe
dans la panique et l'anarchie des
centaines d'afghans s'accroche au
fuselage d'un appareil américain une
tentative désespérée de fuir le pays la
prochaine images déchirantes un afghan
semble tombée de cet avion
des dizaines de milliers de
ressortissants occidentaux et leurs
alliés afghans doivent être évacués mais
les américains ont dû interrompre
l'opération dépassé par le désordre et
la confusion
acheter un square les berlinois de ce
jeu sur la défensive depuis la chute de
kaboul le président by day n'a voulu
défendre sa décision de quitter
l'afghanistan
quel
chemin ils feront du nord dans le nord
les forces afghanes elle-même honte
abandonnées dit il les américains n'ont
pas mourir à leur place pas question
donc de s'acharner comme on l'a fait à
l'époque du vietnam à wana 2 de 9,15 la
crédibilité du président est toutefois
entachée lui qui soutenait il y à un
mois à peine que la chute du
gouvernement afghan et est extrêmement
improbable
une prédiction imprudente selon
d'anciens militaires qui estime que la
maison blanche aurait dû voir venir la
menace
[Musique]
le scénario du pire s'est concrétisée
déplore cet ancien officier
nous avons laissé tomber des dizaines de
milliers d'afghans compter sur nous
ajoute celle ci cela me brise le coeur
car à voir ces images de talibans
dominant les rues de kaboul l'identité
des nouveaux maîtres du pays ne fait
plus aucun doute
[Musique]
notre seul objectif est de maintenir
l'ordre public assure celui ci mais rien
pour rassurer ces millions de femmes
effrayer dont l'avenir semble
irrémédiablement compromis de longues
années d'études ne veulent maintenant
plus rien dire ça triste celle ci
la douleur est énorme ajoute cet autre
nous avons mis tant d'efforts à
reconstruire ce pays le président
français promet d'apporter tout son
soutien les femmes afghanes ont le droit
de vivre dans la liberté et la dignité
et si le destin de l'afghanistan est
entre ses mains nous resterons
fraternellement aux côtés des afghanes
des afghans mais ils ne précisent pas
commun les puissances occidentales
pourrons y parvenir alors que les
talibans contrôlent maintenant tout
l'afghanistan